500 m pour tout donner ces jeunes
cyclistes étaient surmotivés ce dimanche
lui laissons à l'occasion du championnat
régional de cyclo cross
le rendez vous organisé sur l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines a
réuni des catégories de sportifs de 6
ans jusqu'aux professionnels nous ont
beau avoir 10 ans 12 ans ils sont à bloc
ils n'ont qu'une envie c'est peut-être
un jour rejoindre le niveau
professionnel
aujourd'hui les conditions de course ne
sont pas idéales le thermomètre affiche
-2 8 degrés la pluie s'est chargé de
pimenter encore un peu plus le parcours
c'est une véritable condition
cyclo-cross la boule appuyé le vent bah
c'est ça le cyclo-cross soir à la sortie
de la course première réaction pour sept
pilotes de l'extrême j'ai trouvé cette
course c'est c'est alors tout ce qu'ils
fissent labour gestion des du vélo
parfois même mais je roulais vite un
petit peu plus tôt difficile à monter
parce la première elle était plutôt
facile je les réussis mais la deuxième
il y avait tellement de gars doux que
j'y arrivais pas le rendez vous
reviendra l'année prochaine sur l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines les
organisateurs aimeraient également
organiser une coupe de france de la
discipline dans quatre ans